[Music]
welcome back to the heavy spoilers show
I'm your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down episode 3 of the bad batch
season 2. this entry puts Crosshair on
the crosshairs and we watch him carrying
out Imperial missions for the Empire
cross air has always been a fascinating
character to me and he's basically the
evil twin but well cloned to the rest of
the bad batch in season one there was a
lot of back and forth over the chips in
the Troopers heads that activated order
66. it was so for a while a Crosshair
was simply following orders because is
it activated whereas the rested
malfunctioned in these highly altered
clones wreck even went in full attack
mode at one point and it was only upon
this being removed that he finally came
back to the light it was suspected that
Crosshair still had the chip in his head
but he revealed in the two-part finale
that he'd had it removed a while back
obviously the idea of the Empire would
be attractive to some and though we tend
to side with the Jedi in Rebels some
people obviously saw the earlier of it
they promised peace and prosperity in a
galaxy overrun with gangsters and the
resistance didn't really fix things that
much either when they got in charge now
this video is sponsored by the Empire
where I'm allowing you guys to sign up
today now it kind of sounds like I'm
siding with them but I like that the
series is basically you're made from uni
who's like well I can see things from
both sides now the episode is titled the
solitary clone which you initially think
might be a reference to Crosshair this
is definitely possible too and the
episode even ends with him walking
towards the camera in the opposite
direction of the Clones showing how
their mentalities are moving in opposite
directions however I see this more as
being in order to the one he teams up
with AKA your boy Commander Cody Cody
was known as cz2224 and he's quite a big
character in the Star Wars lore Cody has
appeared in live action and he was the
one who received the message to kill
Obi-Wan during Revenge of the Sith he's
also appeared in over to any Clone Wars
Episodes zany was name dropped in Rebels
2. mccody did help to enslave kashyyk
and after turning on his allies he
likely questioned what it was all for in
this entry to me he very much represents
a descent at starting to rise up in the
Clones though he initially thought that
they were phased out because of the
events of last season it also seems like
they started to disobey direct orders
and think for themselves this was shown
last week in Wilco who refused to alter
a report for Rampart also huge shout
outs to everyone on our last video for
pointing out that the name Wilco could
be a reference to the military term will
comply now start off with an outpost on
desex that's approached by an imperial
transport on board or governor and some
phase one Stormtroopers who are slowly
taking the Clones place due to the costs
and the fact that the poker city was no
more these suits are based on the
original Ralph Macquarie designs and he
pretty much created all the first looks
for Lucas when he was coming up with the
concept of Star Wars I love the way
they've integrated them into the series
and it's such a smart way to pay tribute
to what's come before they arrive in an
nu-class attack shuttle which when you
say it different is new class like a new
new class and the citizens Fleet is
straight upon their arrival and we see
rodians along with all sorts of species
running about the area that then come
face to face with the real governor of
the planet Tony Ames she's a Dooku Ally
and a separatist which explains why she
has battle droids and droiticus later on
governors of planets have taken a big
Focus recently in Star Wars with us even
getting an episode centered around
Warden and Ahsoka during the Mandalorian
season 2. the Imperial Governor is here
to replace her but after they refuse
they take their forces captive which is
when crosshairs called in now we see
Crosshair on a planet that looks very
similar to korosand and the building
itself to me is meant to resemble a Jedi
Temple I think this is to show how the
image of it has been desecrated and
later on when we get a shot of it you
can see two balls at the top that look
identical to the ones on Star Destroyers
curta the mess hall which is very
reminiscent of the early scenes on
topoka City in season one we hear clones
talking to each other and they say I
heard the defense recruitment bill is up
for a vote again well let's hope it
doesn't pass for our sake obviously this
bill passed and it potentially meant
that the Empire could completely get rid
of clones instead of having to use them
clones were people I think so they still
had rights but this bill could mean that
they could cut them off and force
citizens in the conscription it could
operate similar to The Republic military
enhancement bill which was put forth by
Senator Haley Bitoni this deregulated
the banks and also offered additional
lines of credit to the Empire so they
could pay more for troops which caused
the surgeon people enlisting they do a
mean girl on Crosshair and move tables
and lahon Lee I Mr Lonely also a little
copy has looked some of the one that
Luke has in a new Hub when he had lunch
with his aunt and uncle had they had a
roast dinner after that hey anyway this
solitary figure solitary clone let's
call him is called him by rumpot we
discovered that he spent 32 rotations on
kamino and that when they left him on
the platform at the end of season one
had he stayed there for weeks on end the
Empire clearly didn't really care about
him and they probably only picked him up
because they were passing Rampart
doesn't know why crossair even returned
after that but he says I'm a soldier of
the empire
you values what they bring above his
family and without the Imperials he
likely doesn't feel like he has a
purpose in life he just wants orders and
he's sent in under the guise it's a
diplomatic Mission this is something
we've seen in Star Wars before and it's
what Qui-Gon and Obi-Wan did at the
start of phantom menace he's not given
his own unit and instead he falls under
the control of Commander Cody who then
meet at the war memorial which has
appeared in Clone Wars before this
showed up in the Jedi Who Knew Too Much
and it documents all the fallen soldiers
who died so Palpatine could [ __ ] about
akodi's uniform used to have flourishes
of color in it however when the Empire
took over this was toned down this very
much represents Conformity and this is
why all uniforms are either white gray
or black juxtaposing this last week's
show that the bad batch had started to
integrate color into their costumes
showing how they now differ from the
ones that stayed in line now you will
stay in line and conform by liking this
video subscribing and sharing it sharing
it with your bloody WhatsApp group I
want all I'm watching it anyway he also
has a scar on his head and eye which is
a characteristic that he's had
throughout the Saga Crosshair says the
bad batch were Traders like the Jedi and
this clearly rubs Cody the wrong way
like we mentioned earlier he wrestled
back and forth with his portrayal of
Obi-Wan and didn't truly understand why
he carried this out the bear trusted one
another but he turned his guns on him
and as they say good soldiers followers
this is of course a line to all the
times it's been said before which we
might have a compilation of but if we
don't it's because we were too lazy to
edit it good soldiers
good soldiers
[Music]
so either it was there it wasn't and
this part of the Clone programming is
something that they constantly spout off
almost to repress what it is that
they've done it of course is links back
to World War II and many of the Germans
are carried out horrific crimes said
that they did so because they were
simply following orders they then passed
two giant monuments to the Clone and
board the shuttle to desex we hear
mention of how the battle droid should
have been shut down but that they've
likely been reprogrammed which I think a
lot of the planet will have done
secretly mathematically this season
seems to be focusing a lot on Dooku's
Legacy he seems to be having a big
Revival in Star Wars recently with tales
of the Jedi also showing a lot of his
backstory too guessing Disney's made a
deal where they don't have to pay
Christopher Lee's family or they they've
found some common ground with the estate
so they can pump out constant Dooku
content either way we are clearly seeing
a lot of things in a series season
showing the aftermath of his actions
were things are the way that they urge
you to what he didn't who followed him
Dooku is brought up by Ames and she says
that everything he predicted has come to
pass in Italy it's seen for Attack of
the Clones who was a lot of talk about
his motivation and how he realized that
this entire thing would play out the way
it has we see the shuttle pilot along
with his helmet and this also looks
similar to the one that was shown in
Sid's bar battle droids are back with
their sassy attitude and we watch
Governor vs governor with one
representing freedom and the other
representing fascism Ames is predicted
the Diplomatic vessel is actually a ruse
and this could have been correctly
guessed due to her having attacked Droid
these tactical droids were Master
strategists and we even had a Clone Wars
episode where there were missions to
steal their chips due to the information
they possessed very difficult to combat
they could work out millions of
scenarios inform strategies that would
lead them to Victory but when it came to
the Jedi they were no match for the
force now the droids all roll out and we
can also see an a80 battle tank which we
could catch in the runes of the second
episode last week I think the Runes of
War entry kinda show what would have
happened if they'd lost this location
and the Empire would have likely rained
fire from the sky had they not got the
victory here now they bring down the
shuttle and the Troopers burst out with
Crosshair now wearing a helmet that
looks a lot more like a Stormtroopers
originally he didn't have the great
mouthpiece but the character now has it
so it looks closer to their eventual
design Crosshair refers to the droid's
clankers which is a nickname they were
given in the war and eventually he takes
the tank out through knowledge of their
weakness man hits the bullseye and it
shows how valuable Crosshair is to the
war effort slowly he and the rest of the
Clones storm The Fortress they used
grappling guns to pull themselves up
like what we saw in The Phantom Menace
in this street they come across a family
and they say they're here to help but
it's clear that those undesics don't
want to be freed by the Empire it will
just mean they're back under the control
of a fascist dictatorship which brings a
lot of social commentary with it
nadrotic is then roll in leading to one
of the most hectic scenes in the season
Jedi knew to run from these and they
have to use stun grenades in order to
make their way through at this point
they're sworn by a different kind of
battle droid and these are the BX series
dried Commandos these were highly
specialized and used in more extreme
conditions which is why we don't see
them all that much in The Saga due to
them being an advanced model they
brought a hefty price tag with him so it
shows how against the wall that the
governor is when she starts to activate
more of them love seeing Crosshair
Ricochet shots around the steps to get
them and it adds so much to the scene
with them swarming the stairwell he
takes out the tactroid and then we see
the flame Trooper bursting out some fire
flame Troopers have shown up throughout
the Saga with them appearing in the
Mandalorian season 1 and also popping up
in the force awakens Tony arrives
holding the Imperial Governor hostage
and she demands that her planet is
acknowledges being independent we see
how the Clones be themselves as
liberating the people of desex whereas
aim sees herself as defending the planet
from a hostile Nation the Empire of
course the bad guys you know things are
framed as being From crosshair's
perspective the good people definitely
got the separatists with this in mind it
kind of makes you view the Clone Wars
differently as we had the separatists as
the bad guys in that but they were
placed by an even bigger bat and poor
old people like Roman were the ones
Stuck in the Middle is what elevates the
animated show above a lot of the other
ones and I love the layers to the series
we of course have the planet wanting to
go independent and many of the Clones do
too do them seeing what the Empire does
so you have this poetry that rhymes with
the planet going independent and also
the Poetry that rhymes with the Clones
doing it as well now Tony says that she
put forth the treaty ones to end the war
between the separatists and Republic but
that the Supreme Chancellor denied this
he was of course playing both teams and
he's basically a mate that says I can
see things from both sides also shout
out store added a math for putting out
that she mentions Mina pontary who is a
character that also appeared in the
Clone Wars she was a mentor to Padme and
also represented the planet underen in
the Senate atone says peace was never an
option but Cody gives her it as he
doesn't want another War to begin after
they've just got through the last one
she hands the governor over who then
demands Tony is executed the final words
are so much for Peace by that Cody
refuses to carry this out and instead
hits Crosshair who does the aims her
surnames Ames in his Crosshair anyway
this again lines up with the idea that
clones are slowly starting to think for
themselves and couple with Wilco we've
seen them disobey direct orders twice
now it is possible that order 66 broke
the clones and killing their allies is
what made them question following the
imps either way they seize the planet
and we see the Star Destroyer in the sky
this often spells doom and it's of
course what we also saw on Jeddah in
Rogue one Imperials used to harvest
planets for minerals and their rule led
to oppression and civil unrest this is a
terrifying site for all of population as
it hangs over the planet ever watching
and unmoving soldiers Patrol the streets
and The Descendants are round up with a
mother and son from a Four's house being
searched supplies are given to the
Empire by the people and we very much
get the feeling that this once free city
is now occupied by military rule Cody
clearly wrestles with his two as we see
more soldiers coming in and he puts his
helmet back on almost as if to fall back
in line however there is clearly doubt
within him and I very much view him as
the solitary clone that the title's
referring to after he returns home he
asks Crosshair flat out if they're
making the Galaxy better he says that
the only thing that makes them different
from the battle droids is that they make
their own choices but with this comes
the fact that they have to live with
them too is clearly torments Crosshair
and we get a shot of him waking up which
Echoes the one from the opening he is
simply like a Droid now just following
orders because he doesn't know what else
to live for you very much get a repeat
of the earlier scenes within visiting
the Cantina sitting on his own and then
going to rampod rampod is even in the
exact same position with the data pad
being presented to the camera like how
it was earlier in the episode he tells
him to report the Clone leader cc1226
who is a character that has been
mentioned in this Saga before but only
in the books he appeared at three points
in the essential guide to Warfare and
was listed as featuring in several of
the big battles unlike Cody he doesn't
have a nickname and this could represent
him still being in line with the Empire
and we find out that Cody has gone AWOL
and my guess is that we're gonna see him
at some point in the future Cody was
actually meant to feature in the Obi-Wan
series and originally when this was a
film the Jedi would come across him on
Tatooine it was revealed that he'd had
his chip removed so that he wouldn't
hurt the Jedi and he was going to become
his ally once more similar to Revenge of
the Sith it was said that Cody wrestle
with the guild award is 66 and he was
trying to make things right in the
Galaxy before his accelerated agent got
the best of him as we know this was Kurt
but I can imagine that we will see him
again at some point Rampart is now a
descent amongst the clones and he even
questions the Loyalty of Crosshair who
heads out on his next mission that ends
the episode and I think the season is
very much gonna head off in a Direction
with him finally becoming independent he
could possibly be seeing the fall of the
empire do and that closes it all off and
I have to say I really enjoy this entry
got to see it twice before released and
it's rare I go back to these things but
this was one I got swept up in love the
way we saw the other side of the fight
and hopefully we get some Crosshair
Centric episodes that show the Clones
slowly standard thing for themselves
anyway that closes things off and I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it if you
are in competition right now and giving
away Dawn of the Dead and Black Adam 3
subscribers on the 15th of January and
all you have to do to be when the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe and notifications on drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode you want some else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown from last week or got
something else on screen right now that
you you might like Anyway without the
weight thanks for sending me for the
video I hate these long intros and I'll
see you next time take care peace